en este video lo que quiero hacer es
resolver un problema que puede parecer
difícil para los estudiantes de primer
año de física y es probable que no se
encuentren con este tipo de problemas en
esos primeros cursos de Física Pero es
un tipo de problema bastante interesante
ya que ahora vamos a lanzar un proyectil
no sobre planos eh a diferente altura
sino sobre un plano inclinado vamos a
tener este
plano tenemos Este es el nivel del
suelo más o menos este Okay Está mejor y
el proyectil lo vamos a lanzar desde
aquí Este es mi proyectil va a tener una
velocidad de 10 m sobre segundo y
esta sobre el ángulo de este proyectil
encima del plano inclinado van a ser 15
gr sin embargo el ángulo a su vez de
este plano con respecto a la horizontal
va a ser
de 30
gr entonces No podemos eh usar la
fórmula que hemos usado eh los videos
anteriores ya que este pues no sabemos
aún En dónde va a caer el proyectil y
dependiendo de dónde caiga sobre este
plano inclinado Eh pues va a ser el
desplazamiento vertical o la altura que
va a tener entonces lo que va a hacer el
proyectil cuando lo
Lance va a describir una curva más o
menos
así y bueno dependiendo de dónde caiga
es la altura que va a tener y
dependiendo de eso es que podré yo
entonces calcular el desplazamiento
Bueno entonces qué es lo que tenemos que
hacer siempre en estos problemas siempre
lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
descom poner las componentes o los
elementos verticales y horizontales del
vector velocidad Entonces mi vector el
componente de mi velocidad va a ser
componente
vertical mi componente vertical de la
velocidad es igual a la magnitud de 10
esto lo vamos a hacer más rápido porque
ya hemos visto todos los elementos
trigonométricos para descomponer los el
os de un vector Entonces vamos a omitir
eso para irnos más
rápido va a ser vamos a usar la función
seno pero tengan cuidado aquí
porque el ángulo que vamos a usar no es
el de 15 gr es el de este total de
ángulos que viene siendo 15 más 30
entonces van a ser 10 por el seno de 45
gr ese va a ser mi componente vertical y
de la misma manera mi componente
horizontal que vamos a ponerlo en otro
color para que se note mi componente
horizontal de la
velocidad va a ser igual a eh la
magnitud en este caso por el coseno de
gr ahora usaremos la fórmula del
desplazamiento vertical que será o que
usará nuestra velocidad
inicial tenemos que nuestra velocidad
inicial o nuestra nuestra velocidad en
el componente vertical va a ser
igual
a 10 el seno de 45 gr es
ra2 entre 2 y esto es igual a 10 / 2 es
5 5 *
ra2 m sobre segundo no voy a estar
usando las unidades para ahorrarme el
espacio al escribir las fórmulas de la
misma manera si simplifico el componente
horizontal de la velocidad va a ser
igual a 10 en este caso el coseno de 45
gr
es también í 2 / 2 y viene siendo
entonces í 2 / 2 y nos va quedando igual
que es 5 * ra2 el componente horizontal
usando la fórmula del
desplazamiento el
desplazamiento va a ser igual a mi
velocidad inicial que mi velocidad
inicial es 5 *
ra2 multiplicado por el cambio en el
tiempo más nuestra aceleración que
recordamos que nuestra aceleración como
va hacia abajo recordamos nuevamente la
convención vectores que van hacia arriba
van a representarse su dirección por una
cantidad positiva vectores que van hacia
abajo se representan con una cantidad
negativa vectores que van hacia la
derecha van a ser representados también
con cantidad positiva vectores que van
hacia la izquierda irán con una
representados con una cantidad negativa
la aceleración va hacia abajo la
aceleración de la gravedad por lo que
esta Va a ser
menos 9.8
por el cambio en el tiempo al
cuadrado
entre
dos y este es mi
desplazamiento mi desplazamiento
vertical tengo que agregarle aquí mi
desplazamiento
vertical Okay entonces vamos a
simplificar un poco más esta expresión
mi desplazamiento vertical es igual a 5
raí de 2 cambio en el tiempo Delta
t - 9.8 / 2 es ig
4.9 también multiplicado por Delta t
Pero esto será al
cuadrado ahora veamos el desplazamiento
horizontal como función del tiempo mi
desplazamiento
horizontal
s de X es igual a mi velocidad en el
horizontal por el cambio en el tiempo mi
velocidad o mi desplazamiento mi
velocidad el componente horizontal de la
velocidad es igual a 5 por
ra2 por el cambio en el tiempo Delta
t Okay qué vamos a hacer ahora Bueno lo
que debemos hacer es encontrar una
relación entre el
desplazamiento vertical y el
desplazamiento horizontal en lo que es
el
desplazamiento horizontal voy a ponerlo
en otro color vamos a poner un verde el
desplazamiento es desde dónde se lanzó
el
proyectil este va a ser mi
desplazamiento horizontal y el
desplazamiento vertical es este la
altura hasta donde cayó en sobre este
plano inclinado y este lo voy a poner en
otro color más o menos aquí Este es mi
desplazamiento vertical tengo aquí las
fórmulas que ambas son con respecto al
tiempo pero me hace falta algo que me
relacione estos dos vectores para que yo
pueda encontrar el valor del cambio en
el tiempo y la el punto de este plano
donde cae es el que nos va va a dar la
relación entre ambos componentes
horizontales y
verticales si aquí es donde cae el
proyectil como les digo esta es nuestra
componente vertical y esta será nuestra
componente horizontal y Aquí vamos a
conocer el ángulo o conocemos el ángulo
voy a usar otro
color Este es el ángulo
de El desplazamiento porque bueno va a
caer
aquí así que sabemos que esto es un
ángulo recto entonces podemos usar eh
nuestras funciones trigonométricas
conocemos o tenemos la fórmula del
desplazamiento horizontal conocemos la
fórmula del desplazamiento vertical y eh
queremos conocer esta relación y a estos
elementos eh la función trigonométrica
que los relaciona es el cateto opuesto y
el cateto adyacente va a ser nuestra
función
tangente y conocemos el ángulo la
tangente va a ser de 30 gr Así que voy a
escribir que mi tangente de 30 gr va a
ser igual a el cateto opuesto que viene
siendo mi componente o la magnitud de mi
componente vertical del
desplazamiento entre el componente
horizontal
sx
tenemos estos conocemos estos
elementos sí sabemos que aparte bueno la
tangente de 30
gr voy a escribirlo
acá la tangente de 30 gr va a ser igual
al seno de 30 gr entre el coseno de 30
gr el seno de 30 gr es igual a
1/2 el coseno de 30 gr es igual a
√3 ent 2 por lo que este valor tangente
es igual a 1/2 por raíz Perdón por
2 Entre
ra3 esto se elimina y la tangente de 30
gr es igual a 1 sobre
ra3 así que tenemos que 1
a ver voy a cambiar el
color 1 sobre
ra3 que es el valor de mi
tangente disculpen que me salga un poco
chueco 1 sobre ra TR que es la tangente
de 30 gr va a ser igual a mi
desplazamiento vertical a la
magnitud de mi
desplazamiento
vertical
entre mi desplazamiento
horizontal Así que ahora por ejemplo
puedo decir simplificando esto nos queda
por ejemplo raíz de 3 multiplicado
por la
componente vertical es
igual a nuestra componente
horizontal y teniendo ya esto Entonces
vamos a eh aquí ya tenemos la relación
de ambos vectores vamos a sustituir esto
dentro de una de las fórmulas de las que
ya tenemos por ejemplo esta de s la
desplazamiento vertical es igual a 5 por
ra2 el cambio en el tiempo tenemos
entonces que ya calculamos voy a dejar
de usar esto de la magnitud porque vamos
a usar los componentes o los elementos
positivos ya que la dirección de ambos
vectores tanto la horizontal como la
vertical van a ser pues este
positivos entonces de esta
fórmula tengo que este mi componente
vertical es igual
a
ra3 por la componente vertical y esto es
igual
5 * raí 2 Ay Dios raíz de 2 el cambio en
el
tiempo ahora quiero dejar todo en
función del cambio en el
tiempo el cambio en el
tiempo es igual
a raí
3 multiplicado por el
desplazamiento voy a poner en el color
morado original desplazamiento en el
tiempo Perdón del desplazamiento
vertical entre 5 por
ra2
entre 5 por
ra2 lo que estoy haciendo aquí es
despejar el cambio en el tiempo para
dejar todo en términos del
desplazamiento vertical con esta voy a
este substituir todos los elementos de
desplazamiento en el tiempo en esta
Fórmula en esta de aquí o en esta que ya
está
simplificada por lo que me va a
quedar desplazamiento en el tiemp en
desplazamiento en el tiempo Okay no
desplazamiento vertical el componente
vertical es igual a
5 por raí 2 por el cambio en el tiempo
el cambio en el tiempo es todo estos
elementos
voy a poner estro color que
es
ra3 por 5 ent
ra2 por el
desplazamiento
vertical y esto Esto es este término
menos
4.9
4.9 por el desplazamiento en el tiempo
al
cuadrado que viene
siendo este mismo raí 3 ent 5 *
ra2 por mi desplazamiento
eh el
vertical Así que aquí ya tengo una
ecuación
cuadrática toda este En referencia a una
sora variable que es es el
desplazamiento vertical Entonces
simplificando esto me va a
quedar voy a bajar un poco aquí para
tener más
espacio mi desplazamiento
vertical es igual
a estos elementos se anulan entonces me
va a quedar que es igual a
ra3 í
3 por mi
desplazamiento
vertical menos Bueno vamos a poner en
otro color
menos
4.9
multiplicado í 3 cu va a ser igual a 3
5 cuad es
25 í 2 cu es 2 25 * 2 es igual a
50 Entonces 3 / 50 por el desplazamiento
vertical al
cuadrado dejándolo con los términos de
una ecuación cuadrática dejamos que 0 es
igual a desplazamiento
vertical y podemos
incluso dejarlo
así como
ra3 - 1 si este desplazamiento e
vertical lo paso de este lado de la
ecuación va a estar con una signo
negativo y aquí lo estoy juntando con
este elemento y por eso estoy
factorizando el desplazamiento vertical
multiplicado por í 3 - 1 menos esta
sección de
acá
menos
4.9
por 3
50 por desplazamiento vertical al
cuadrado nuestro desplazamiento vertical
entonces puede ser igual a 0 de hecho
este elemento eh desplazamiento vertical
lo puedo factorizar de dejarlo afuera eh
de los términos de la ecuación me va a
quedar cer0 es igual
a mi
desplazamiento
vertical
multiplicado
por √3 -
1 -
1 menos
4.9 por 3
50 desplazamiento
vertical de esta manera puedo yo ver que
tengo dos elementos que me resuelven
esta ecuación si esta eh desplazamiento
vertical es cer0 al multiplicarlo por
todo esto Pues bueno va a ser igual a
cer este es de hecho el inicio el
desplazamiento inicial cuando me
encuentro en este punto de lanzamiento
que apenas estoy lanzando el proyectil
pero lo que me interesa conocer es este
desplazamiento el desplazamiento final
qu ocurre cuando esta parte de la
ecuación es igual a 0 Así que voy a
resolver para encontrar el valor del
desplazamiento vertical en esta parte
por lo que me queda que 0 es igual a la
raí 3 -
1 -
4.9 * 3
50 por el desplazamiento
vertical si yo hago los cálculos este
valor y los invito Bueno ya los hice
para ahorrar
tiempo esta parte de la ecuación esto es
un valor igual a 0.73 lo pueden resolver
con su calculadora y esta sección de
-4.9
este es igual a
0.294 entonces 0 es igual a 0.73
men pun
desplazamiento
vertical vamos a
resolverlo nos
queda 0.73 3 esto lo dejo aquí esto lo
paso del otro lado de la igualdad y me
va a quedar que es igual
a
0.294
desplazamiento vertical quiero dejar
despejar este desplazamiento vertical
Esto me va a quedar igual
a
0.73 entre
0.294 finalmente ya podemos tener el
valor del desplazamiento vertical Casi
casi se merecen unas
fanfarrias esta operación que ustedes la
pueden hacer en sus calculadoras resulta
igual a 2.49 m Este es mi desplazamiento
vertical Este es el que se
encuentra
2.49 metros es este valor la magnitud y
bueno hacia arriba indica la dirección
que el desplazamiento es hacia arriba es
un desplazamiento con dirección
positiva ahora ya puedo usar esto para
calcular mi desplazamiento eh horizontal
Esta es la fórmula de mi desplazamiento
horizontal Así que vamos a
sustituirla
tenemos que el desplazamiento
horizontal voy a poner de este
lado es igual a raí
3 raí
3 por este valor de desplazamiento
vertical por
punto 49 Met y este desplazamiento
vertical su valor es igual a 4.3
Met de nuevo Los invito a que lo hagan
con la calculadora entonces
este lo voy a cambiar de color es
4.31 m mi desplazamiento
horizontal ahora eh Ya que tenemos ambos
componentes les dejo a ustedes que
calculen Cuál es el desplazamiento total
en esta dirección ya tienen los
elementos
eh los componentes vertical y
horizontal con eso usando una función el
teorema de Pitágoras
pueden calcular este
desplazamiento
total